canceling birthright citizenship would
be legally difficult Donald Trump has
said he's interested in it he's
interested in exploring canceling
birthright citizenship but for now if
you are born in the physical United
States you are a citizen unless Donald
Trump gets that changed it's not
happening in the immediate but the Trump
administration has maybe found a sort of
preemptive proxy to test eliminating
birthright citizenship and the Trump
administration has changed the policy
for children born to some military
service members and other government
employees and diplomats physically
outside the borders of the United States
historically if you were born in an
overseas military base or if your
parents are diplomats and you're born in
a foreign hospital I've friends who are
in this situation right now while your
parents or parent is on diplomatic duty
you are automatically an American
citizen it's just it's an automatic
thing that takes place the Trump
administration is changing this now
they're not eliminating it they are
changing the process starting October
29th the process is going to change to
one where the parents must apply for
citizenship before their kid turns 18
interestingly I went through this
process to become a citizen when my
parents became citizens I then had the
possibility of becoming a citizen up
until age 18 merely by going through a
simple administrative procedure so for
people who don't know I and my parents
were all born in Argentina in 1989 my
family came to the United States from
Argentina as permanent residents I was
five years old at the time and then I
think it must have been the mid to late
90s my parents became citizens of the US
they had been here I believe it was
seven years at the time as permanent
residents they went through the process
they had the entire thing it was then up
to me whether I wanted to become a
citizen now I had two options if I
waited until age 18 and did not become a
citizen I would have to go through the
entire process from the beginning I
would have to apply I would have to have
the interview and the entire thing but
until age 18 my parents could simply go
to the post office and request a
passport for me and I would
automatically become a citizen of the
United States and that's what we did the
new Trump policy is that
if your parents are US citizens but you
happen to be born abroad in a number of
these situations not all of them you
need to be naturalized as the phrase is
as the word is just like I had to be
naturalized as someone who immigrated to
the United States from another country
this is ridiculous and it's especially
ridiculous because it serves no real
purpose other than a bureaucratic
obstacle there is no advantage to this
there is no benefit to this the
explanation that the USCIS is giving
this is the US Citizenship and
Immigration Services they're saying that
this is to align federal immigration law
with State Department procedures this is
a completely incredible explanation by
incredible I mean it is it is not
believable it is not credible this is
merely a continuation of the trends that
we've been seeing with Donald Trump
Trump's not good to the military this is
a continuation of that Trump attacks
goal start gold star families this is a
continuation of that Trump attacked
prisoner of war John McCain for being a
prisoner of war saying he prefers his
war heroes not be captured or whatever
the case may be and now he wants to
strip military and diplomatic babies of
automatic citizenship that's it that's
the storyline that's the explanation and
if these people if people reacted to
these things correctly the military
would turn on Trump and not vote for him
in 2020 the farmers would already have
turned on Trump and would not be voting
for him in 2020 as we've been covering
and in the background you only need to
look at who's running the USCIS it's Ken
Cuccinelli Ken Cuccinelli is an
extremist ideologue Republican who has
previously said he would like to ban
oral sex he's a horrible person
he's the acting director of USCIS of
course there's no permanent director as
is the trend the status quo under Donald
Trump but Ken Cuccinelli is the acting
director and the reality of this is that
this is a test to see can Trump take a
baby step closer to repealing birthright
citizenship altogether can he get this
through and make birthright citizenship
in total the next thing that he wants to
repeal we should not be confused
the real objectives here they are
terrible they are the lowest of the low
and the question is will Donald Trump be
given another four years with which to
try to do more of this stuff let me know
what you think about this let me know
what you think about the prospects of
Trump reelection as of now on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is also on twitter at
david pakman show follow us both and
make sure that you are watching the live
streams that I'm doing on twitch at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman blinka is a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli n ki st.com /pa ke ma n